The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Well, I guess I
really should have
said "goodbye," because
this is the last lecture
in our course--
not the last assignment,
but the last lecture.
The reason I said "hi" was,
why quit after all this time
with saying that?
And we've reached
the stage now where
we should clean up
the vector spaces
to the best of our
ability and recognize
that, from this point on, much
of the treatment of vector
spaces requires
specialized concentration.
In fact, I envy
the real people who
make regular movies
where they have
stuntmen when things get tough.
I would continue on
with this course,
except that I don't
have a stuntman
to do these hard
lectures for me.
And also, the particular
topic, as I told you last time,
that I have in mind for
today-- the subject called
eigenvectors--
has two approaches to it.
One is that it does have
some very elaborate practical
applications, many
of which occur
in more advanced subjects.
It also has a very
nice framework
within the game of
mathematics idea.
And my own feeling was that,
since we started this course
with the concept of the
game of mathematics,
mathematical
structures, I thought
that, rather than go into
complicated applications,
I would treat
eigenvectors in terms
of the structure of
mathematics as a game.
In fact, as an
interesting aside,
I'd like to share with
you a very famous story
in mathematics, that, when the
first book on matrix algebra
was written by Hamilton,
he inscribed the book with,
"Here at last is a
branch of mathematics
for which there will never be
found practical application."
He did not invent the subject
to solve difficult physics
problems.
He invented the
subject because it was
an elegant mathematical device.
And so I thought that
maybe, for our last lecture,
we should end on that vein.
At any rate, the subject for
today is called eigenvectors.
And from a purely game point
of view, the idea is this.
Let's suppose that we
have a vector space V
and a linear mapping, a
linear transformation, f,
that maps V onto itself, say.
And the question is, are
there any vectors in V other
than the zero vector,
such that f of v
is some scalar multiple of v?
You see, the reason I exclude
the zero vector, first of all,
is that we already know that,
for a linear transformation,
f of 0 is 0.
And c times 0 is 0 for all c.
So this would be trivially
true if v were the zero vector.
So what we're really
interested in--
given a particular
linear transformation,
are there any vectors
such that, relative
to that linear transformation,
the mapping of that vector
is just a scalar multiple
of that vector itself?
In other words, does f
preserve the direction
of any vectors in V?
By the way, don't confuse
this with conformal mapping
that we talked about
in complex variables.
In conformal mapping, we didn't
preserve any-- in general,
we did not preserve
directions of lines.
We preserved angles.
In other words, an
angle might have
been rotated so that the
direction of the two sides
may have changed.
It was the angle
that was preserved
in the conformal mapping.
What we're asking now is,
given a linear transformation,
does it preserve any directions?
And to illustrate this
in terms of an example,
let's suppose we
think of mapping
the xy-plane into the uv-plane
under the linear mapping f
bar, where f bar maps x, y into
the 2-tuple x plus 4y comma
x plus y.
In other words, in terms
of mapping the xy-plane
into the uv-plane,
this is the mapping--
u equals x plus 4y,
v equals x plus y.
It's understood here,
when I'm referring
to the typical xy-plane, that
my basis vectors are i and j.
Notice, by the way, that
if I look at the vector i,
i is the 2-tuple 1 comma 0.
Notice that when x is 1 and
y is 0, u is 1 and v is one.
So f bar maps 1 comma
0 into 1 comma 1.
Again, in terms of
i and j vectors,
f bar maps i into i plus j.
And i plus j is certainly
not a scalar multiple of i.
Similarly, what
does f bar do to j?
j, relative to the basis i and
j, is written as 0 comma 1.
When x is 0 and y is 1, we
obtain that u is 4 and v is 1.
So under f bar, 0 comma 1
is mapped into 4 comma 1.
Or in the language of
i and j components, f
bar maps j into 4i plus j.
And that certainly is not
a scalar multiple of j.
In other words, 4i plus
j is not parallel to j.
On the other hand, let me
pull this one out of the hat.
Let's take the
vector 2i plus j--
in other words, the
2-tuple 2 comma 1.
When x is 2 and y is 1,
we see that x plus 4y is 6
and x plus y is 3.
So f bar maps 2 comma
1 into 6 comma 3.
And that certainly
is 3 times 2 comma
1-- see, by our rule of
scalar multiplication.
In other words, what this says
is that the vector 2i plus j
is mapped into the vector
which has the same sense
and direction as 2i plus
j, but is 3 times as long.
So you see, sometimes
the linear transformation
will map a vector into a
scalar multiple of itself.
Sometimes it won't.
Sometimes there'll
be no vectors,
other than the zero vector,
that they're mapped into--
scalar multiples of themselves,
and things of this type.
But that's not
important right now.
In terms of a game, what
we're trying to do is what?
Solve the equation
[INAUDIBLE]---- well,
let's give it in
terms of a definition.
First of all, if we
have a vector space V,
and f is a linear transformation
mapping V into itself,
if little v is any non-zero
element of the vector space V,
and if f of v equals c
times v for some scalar--
for some number c--
then v is called an eigenvector
and c is called an eigenvalue.
In other words, if a vector
has its direction preserved,
geometrically speaking,
all we're saying
is that if the direction
doesn't change,
the vector is called
an eigenvector.
And the scaling factor--
which means what?
Even though the
direction doesn't change,
the image may have a
different magnitude,
because the scalar c here
doesn't have to be 1.
That scalar is
called an eigenvalue.
And I'll give you more
on this in the exercises,
and perhaps even in
supplementary notes
if the exercises seem
to get too sticky.
But we'll see how
things work out.
For the time being,
all I care about
is that you understand
what an eigenvector means
and what an eigenvalue is.
Quickly summarized, if f maps
a vector space into itself,
an eigenvector is
any non-zero vector
which has its direction
preserved under the mapping f--
that f maps it into a
scalar multiple of itself.
There is a matrix approach
for finding eigenvectors,
and the matrix
approach also gives us
a very nice review of many
of the techniques that we've
used previously in our course.
For the sake of
argument, let's suppose
that V is an n-dimensional
vector space,
and that we've again chosen a
particular basis, u1 up to un,
to represent V.
Suppose, also, that f
is a linear mapping
carrying V into V.
Remember how we used the
matrix approach here?
What we said was, look at.
The vectors u1 up to un
are carried into f of u1
up to f of un.
And that determines the
linear transformation
f because of the fact of
the linearity properties.
In other words, when you
take f of a1 u1 plus a2 u2,
it's just a1 f of
u1 plus a2 f of u2.
So once you know what
happens to the basis vectors,
you know what happens
to everything.
But since we're expressing V in
terms of the basis u1 up to un,
that means that f of
u1, et cetera, f of un
may all be expressed as linear
combinations of u1 up to un.
And that's precisely what
I've written over here.
We also know that the
vector v that we're
trying to find--
see, remember we're
trying to find eigenvectors.
The vector v, relative
to the basis u1 up to un,
can be written as the
n-tuple x1 up to xn.
And now I won't bother
writing this, because I hope,
by this time, you
understand this.
This is an abbreviation
for saying what?
The vector v is x1 u1
plus et cetera xn un,
because I am always referring
to the specific basis
when I write n-tuples without
any other qualifications.
Now, the question was, how did
the statement f of v equal cv
translate in the
language of matrices?
Remember that we took
this particular matrix
of coefficients and wrote--
well, we transposed it.
Remember what we said?
We said that the
matrix A would be
the matrix whose first column
would be the components of f
of u1 and whose nth column would
be the components of f of un.
In other words, what we did was,
is we said that to take f of v,
we would just take the matrix--
notice how I've written it,
now-- not a1,1, a1,2, a1,1,
you see?
a2,1, a3,1, et cetera--
you see, these make up
the components of f of u1.
These make up the
components of f of un.
That's what was
called the matrix A.
v itself was the n-tuple x1 up
to xn, which became the column
matrix X when we wrote
it as a column vector.
Remember that.
And then what we said
was the transpose
of that would be c
times this n-tuple.
But if I write this
n-tuple as a column vector,
I don't need the
transpose in here.
In other words, in
matrix language,
with A being this
matrix and X being
this column matrix, this
translates into the matrix
equation A times X
equals c times X,
where we recall that the
matrix A is what's given,
and what we're trying to
find is, first of all,
are there any vectors X that are
mapped into a scalar times X?
In other words, are
any column matrices
that are mapped into a scalar
times that column matrix
with respect to A?
And secondly, if there are
such column matrices, what
values of c correspond to that?
Well, notice, by ordinary
algebraic techniques--
because matrices do obey many of
the ordinary rules of algebra--
AX equals cX is the same
as saying AX minus cX is 0.
Notice that we already
know that matrices
obey the distributive rule.
In other words, I could factor
out the matrix X from here.
Of course, I have to
be very, very careful.
Notice that capital
A is a matrix.
Little c is a scalar.
And to have A minus c
wouldn't make much sense.
In other words, since
A is an n-by-n matrix,
I want whatever I'm
subtracting from it
to also be an n-by-n matrix.
So what I do is the little
cute device of remembering
the property of the
identity matrix I sub n.
I simply replace X by I sub
n times X-- in other words,
the identity matrix times
X. That now says what?
AX minus c, identity
matrix n-by-n--
identity matrix
times X equals 0.
Now I can factor out
the X. And I have what?
The matrix A minus c
times the identity matrix
times the column
matrix X equals 0.
Now, remember, back
when we were first
talking about matrix
algebra, we pointed out
that matrices obey
the same structure.
Matrices obey the same structure
with certain small reservations
that numbers obey.
For example, we saw that if
A was not the zero matrix,
AX equals zero did not imply
that X equals zero like it
did in ordinary arithmetic.
But it did if A happened to
be a non-singular matrix.
In other words,
what we did show was
that if this particular
matrix had an inverse, then,
multiplying both
sides of this equation
by the inverse of
this, the inverse
would cancel this factor, and
we'd be left with X equals 0.
In other words, if A
minus cI inverse exists,
then X must be the
zero column matrix.
Now, remember what X is.
X is the column
matrix whose entries
are the components of the v that
we're looking for over here.
Keep in mind that we were
looking for a v which
was unequal to zero.
If v is unequal to 0, in
particular, at least one
of its components must
be different from 0.
So what we're saying is, if A--
if this matrix here,
with its inverse, exists,
then X must be the
zero column matrix,
which is the solution
that we don't want.
In other words, we won't
get non-zero solutions.
Or from a different
point of view,
what this says is, if we want
to be able to find a column
vector X which is not the zero
column vector, in particular,
A minus cI had better
be a singular matrix.
In other words, it's
inverse doesn't exist.
And as we saw back in block
4, when a matrix is singular,
it means that its
determinant is 0.
Consequently, in order
for there to be any chance
that we can find non-zero
solutions of this equation,
it must be that the determinant
of A minus cI must be 0.
And by the way, what does
A minus cI look like?
Notice that I is the
n-by-n identity matrix.
When you multiply a
matrix by a scalar,
you multiply each entry of
that matrix by that scalar.
Since all of the entries off
the diagonal are 0, c times 0
will still be 0.
So notice that c times the
n-by-n identity matrix is just
the n-by-n diagonal matrix,
each of whose diagonal elements
is c.
And now, remembering what
A is, and remembering
how we subtract two
matrices, we subtract
them component-by-component.
Notice that the only non-zero
components of cI are the c's
down the diagonal.
What this says is, if we take
our matrix A, A minus c In is
simply, from a
manipulative point of view,
obtained by subtracting c from
each of the diagonal elements.
You see, it's a1,1
minus c, a2,2 minus c.
But every place else,
you're subtracting 0,
because the entry here is 0.
So this is what this
matrix looks like.
I want its determinant to be 0.
Last time, we showed how
we computed a determinant.
Notice that the a's
are given numbers.
c is the only unknown.
If we expand this determinant
and equate it to 0,
we get an nth degree
polynomial in c.
I'm not going to go into
much detail about that now.
In fact, I'm not going to go
into any detail about this now.
I will save that
for the exercises.
But what I will do is take
the very simple case, where
we have a two-dimensional
vector space,
and apply this theory
to the two-by-two case.
And I think that the easiest
example to pick, in this case,
is the same example as we
started with-- example 1--
and revisit it.
In other words, this is
called "example 1 revisited."
That doesn't sound--
Let's just call it example 2.
In example 2, you were thinking
of a two-dimensional space
relative to a particular basis.
The 2-tuple x comma y got mapped
into x plus 4y comma x plus y.
In particular, 1 comma 0
got mapped into 1 comma 1.
0 comma 1 got mapped
into 4 comma 1.
The only reason I've
left the bar off
here is so that you
don't get the feeling
that this has to be
interpreted geometrically.
This could be any
two-dimensional space
relative to any basis.
But at any rate,
using this example,
remembering how the matrix A is
obtained, the first column of A
are these components.
That's 1, 1.
The second column of A
are these components--
4, 1.
So the matrix A
associated with f
relative to our given basis that
represents the 2-tuples here
is 1, 4, 1, 1.
If I want to now look
at A minus c I2--
see, n is 2, in this case--
the two-by-two identity
matrix-- what do I do?
I just subtract c from each
diagonal element this way
so the determinant of
that is this determinant.
We already know how to expand
a two-by-two determinant.
It's this times this
minus this times this.
This is what? c
squared minus 2c.
Plus 1 minus 4 is minus 3.
This is c squared
minus 2c minus 3.
And therefore, the only way
this determinant can be 0
is if this is 0.
This factors into c
minus 3 times c plus 1.
Therefore, it must be that
c is 3 or c is minus 1.
In other words, the only
possible characteristic-- or,
eigenvalues, in this
problem, are 3 and minus 1.
And we'll see what that means
in a moment in terms of looking
at these cases separately.
You may have noticed I
made a slip of the tongue
and said characteristic
values instead of eigenvalues.
You will find, in many
textbooks, the word eigenvalue.
In other books, you'll
find characteristic value.
These terms are used
interchangeably.
Eigenvalue was the
German translation
of characteristic value.
So use these terms
interchangeably, all right?
But let's take a
look at what happens
in this particular example,
in the case that c equals 3.
If c equals 3, this
tells me that my vector v
is determined by f of
v is 3 times v, where
v is the 2-tuple x comma y.
Writing out what this means
in terms of my matrix now,
my matrix A is 1, 4, 1, 1.
v written as a column
vector is this.
And 3 times this
column vector is this.
Remembering that to compare
two matrices to be equal,
they must be equal
entry by entry,
the first entry of
this product is what?
It's x plus 4y.
The second entry is x plus y.
Therefore, it must be
that x plus 4y equals 3x,
and x plus y equals 3y.
And both of these two conditions
together say, quite simply,
that x equals 2y.
And what does that tell us?
It says that if you take any
2-tuple of the form x comma y,
where x is twice y--
in other words, if you take the
set of all 2-tuples 2y comma y,
these are eigenvectors.
And they correspond
to the eigenvalue 3.
And I'm going to show you that
pictorially in a few moments.
I just want you to get
used to the computation
here for the time being.
Secondly, if you want to
think of this geometrically,
x equals 2y doesn't have to
be viewed as a set of vectors.
It can be viewed as
a line in the plane.
And what this says is that
f preserves the direction
of the line x equals 2y.
Oh, just as a quick
check over here--
whichever interpretation
you want--
notice that if you
replace x by 2y--
remember what the
definition of f was?
f was what?
f of x, y was x plus
4y comma x plus y.
So if x is 2y, this
becomes 6y comma 3y.
In other words, f of 2y
comma y is 6y comma 3y.
That's the same as
3 times 2y comma y.
And by the way, notice
that the special case
y equals 1 corresponded to
part of our example number
1, when we showed
that f bar of 2 comma
1 was three times 2 comma 1.
In a similar way,
c equals minus 1
is the other
characteristic value.
Namely, if c equals minus
1, the equation f of v
equals cv becomes f
of v equals minus v.
And in matrix language,
that's AX equals minus X.
Recalling what A and
X are from before,
remember, A times X will be
the column matrix x plus 4y,
x plus y.
Minus X is the column
matrix minus x minus y.
Equating corresponding entries,
we get this pair of equations.
And notice that both
of these equations
say that x must equal minus 2y.
In other words, if the x
component is minus twice the y
component, relative
to the given basis
that we're talking
about here, notice
that the set of all 2-tuples
of the form minus 2y comma y
are eigenvectors,
in this case, and
the corresponding
eigenvalue is minus 1,
and that f preserves
the direction
of the line x equals minus 2y.
And I think, now,
the time has come
to show you what
this thing means
in terms of a simple
geometric interpretation.
Keep in mind, many
of the applications
of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors come up
in boundary value problems of
partial differential equations.
I will show you, in
one of our exercises,
that even our linear homogeneous
differential equations may be
viewed as eigenvector problems.
They come up in
many applications.
But I'm saying, in terms
of the spirit of a game,
let's take the simplest
physical interpretation.
And that's simply the mapping of
the xy-plane into the uv-plane.
And all we're saying is
that the mapping f bar
that we're talking about-- what
mapping are we talking about?
The mapping that
carries x, y into--
what was it that's written down
here? x plus 4y comma x plus y.
What that mapping does is
it changes the direction
of most lines in the plane.
But there are two lines that
it leaves alone in direction.
Namely, the line x equal 2y
gets mapped into the line u
equals 2v, and the
line x equals minus 2y
gets mapped into the
line u equals minus 2v.
By the way, notice we are not
saying that the points remain
fixed here.
Remember that the characteristic
value corresponding
to this eigenvector was 3.
In other words, notice
that 2 comma 1 doesn't get
mapped into 2 comma 1 here.
It got mapped into 6 comma 3--
that the characteristic
value tells you,
once you know what directions
are preserved, how much
the vector was stretched out.
In other words, 2i plus j get
stretched out into 6i plus 3j.
Well, I'm not going to go
into that in any more detail
right now.
All I do want to
observe is that, if I
was studying the
particular mapping f bar,
notice that the lines x equal
2y and x equal minus 2y are,
in a way, a better coordinate
system than the axes x and y,
because notice that the
x-axis and the y-axis
have their directions
changed under this mapping.
But x equals 2y and x
equals minus 2y don't
have their directions changed.
In fact, to look at this
a different way, let's
pick a representative
vector from this line
and a representative
vector from this line.
Let's take y to be 1.
In this case, that
would say x is 2.
In this case, it
says x is minus 2.
Let's pick, as two new vectors,
alpha 1 to be 2i plus j
and alpha 2 to be
minus 2i plus j.
And my claim is--
I'll write them
with arrows here,
as long as we are going to
think of this is a mapping.
My claim is that
alpha 1 and alpha 2
is a very nice basis
for E2 with respect
to the linear transformation f.
Well, y?
Well, what do we already
know about alpha 1?
Alpha 1 is an eigenvector
with characteristic value 3.
In other words, f of
alpha 1 is 3 alpha 1.
Alpha 2 is also an eigenvector
with characteristic value
minus 1.
So f of alpha 2
is minus alpha 2.
Notice, then, therefore, from
an algebraic point of view,
if I pick alpha 1 and alpha
2 as my bases for-- well,
I should be consistent here.
I called this V. I suppose
it should have been E2,
simply to match
the notation here.
But that's not important.
Suppose I pick alpha 1 and
alpha 2 to be my new bases.
Notice, you see, that f of alpha
1 is 3 alpha 1 plus 0 alpha 2.
f of alpha 2 is 0 alpha
1 minus 1 alpha 2.
So my matrix of f, relative to
alpha 1 and alpha 2 as a basis,
would have its first
column being 3 and 0.
It would have its second
column being 0 and minus 1.
In other words, the matrix now
is a diagonal matrix, 3, 0, 0,
minus 1.
It's not only a diagonal matrix,
but the diagonal elements
themselves yield
the eigenvalues.
Notice how easy this matrix
is to use for computing--
A times X-- if X happens to be
written relative to the alphas,
because the easiest type
of matrix to multiply by
is a diagonal matrix.
And I'm not going to go through
this here, but when you write--
when you pick the basis
consisting of eigenvalues,
eigenvectors, and write
this diagonal matrix,
the resulting diagonal
matrix gives you
a tremendous amount
of insight as to what
the space looks like.
And I'll bring that
out in the exercises.
All I want you to get
out of this overview
is what eigenvectors are
and how we compute them.
And I thought that,
to finish up with,
I would like to give you a very,
very profound result, which
I won't prove for you,
but which I will state--
has, also, a profound name.
But I'll get to
that in a moment.
I call this an important aside.
It really isn't an aside.
It's the backbone of much
of advanced matrix algebra.
But the interesting
thing is this.
Remember, given an
n-by-n matrix A,
we were fooling
around with looking
at the determinant of
A minus cI equaling 0
and trying to find a scalar
c that would do this for us.
That's how we get the
characteristic values.
A was the given matrix.
I was the given identity matrix.
c was a scalar
whose value we were
trying to get the determinant
of this matrix to be 0.
The amazing point is that
if you substitute the matrix
A for c, in this equation, it
will satisfy this equation.
And what do I mean by that?
Just replace c by A over here,
and this equation is satisfied.
By the way, that
may look trivial.
You may say to me, gee, whiz.
What a big deal.
If I take c and
replace it by A, this
is A times the
identity matrix, which
is still A. A minus
A is the zero matrix.
And the determinant of the
zero matrix is clearly 0.
The metaphysical thing here
is, notice that c is a number.
It's a scalar.
And A is a matrix.
Structurally, you
cannot let c equal A.
All we're saying is
a remarkable result,
that if you mechanically
replace c by A,
this equation is satisfied.
And before I illustrate that for
you, I've made a big decision.
I'm going to tell you what
this theorem is called.
I wasn't originally
going to tell you that.
It's called the
Cayley-Hamilton theorem.
And by my telling you this
name, you now know as much
about the subject as I do.
That's why I didn't want to
tell you what the name was,
so I'd still know something
more than you did about it.
But that's not too important.
Let me illustrate
how this thing works.
Let's go back to our matrix
1, 4, 1, 1, all right?
The determinant of A
minus cI, we already saw,
was c squared minus 2c minus 3.
My claim is, if I
replace c by A in here,
this will still be obeyed, only
with one slight modification.
See, this becomes what?
A squared minus 2A.
And I can't write minus 3,
because 3 is a number, not
a matrix.
It's always
understood, when you're
converting to matrix form,
that the I is over here.
And if you want to
see why, you can
think of this as being A to the
0, and think of the number 1
as being c to the 0.
In other words,
structurally, this
is A squared minus 2A
minus 3A to the 0 power.
This is c squared minus
2c minus 3c to the 0.
And my claim is
that this equation
will be obeyed by the matrix A.
Let's just check it out
and see if it's true.
Remember that A was
the matrix 1, 4, 1, 1.
To square it means
multiply it by itself.
If I go through the usual
recipe for multiplying
two two-by-two
matrices, I very quickly
see that the product
is 5, 8, 2, 5.
Notice that, since A is 1, 4,
1, 1, multiplying by minus 2
multiplies each
entry by minus 2.
So minus 2A is this matrix.
Notice that minus 3
times the identity matrix
is a diagonal matrix
that has minus 3
as each main diagonal element--
in other words,
this matrix here.
And notice, now, just
for the sake of argument,
if I add these
up, what do I get?
5 minus 2 minus 3, which
is 0, 8 minus 8 plus 0,
which is 0, 2 minus 2 plus 0,
which is 0, 5 minus 2 minus 3,
which is 0.
In other words, this sum
is the zero matrix, not
the zero number.
You see, technically speaking
here, in this equation here,
the 0 refers to a number,
because the determinant
is a number.
But here, we're
talking about, it
satisfied in matrix language.
And what this means is
that matrices can now
be reduced by long division.
So I'll give you a
very simple example.
But what the main
impact of this is,
I can now invent power
series of matrices.
In other words, I can
define e to the x, where
x is a matrix, to be 1
plus x plus x squared over
2 factorial plus x cubed over 3
factorial, et cetera, the same
as we did in scalar cases.
And the main reason is that,
once I'm given a matrix,
and I find the basic polynomial
equation that it satisfies,
I can reduce every
matrix to that.
Let me give you an example.
The key thing I want
you to keep in mind
here is that we already know,
for this particular matrix A,
that A squared minus 2A
minus 3I is the zero matrix.
Suppose, now, I wanted
to compute A cubed.
Now, in this assignment
here I'm going
to show you how I can reduce
matrices by long division.
And in the exercises,
I'll actually
do the long division for you.
But what is long division
in factoring form?
What I'm saying is, I know that
A squared minus 2A minus 3I
is 0.
So I would like to write
A cubed in such a way
that I can factor out an A
squared minus 2A minus 3I.
The way I do that is I notice
that I must multiply A squared
by A in order to get A cubed.
The trouble is, when I
multiply, I now have a minus 2A
squared on the right-hand
side that I don't want,
because it's not here.
And I have a minus 3A on the
right-hand side that I don't
want, because it's not here.
So to compensate for that, I
simply add on a 2A squared,
and I add on a 3A.
In other words,
even though this may
look like a funny
way of doing it,
a very funny way of writing A
cubed is this expression here.
And the reason that I
choose this expression is,
notice that this being 0 means
that A cubed is just 2A squared
plus 3A.
Moreover, notice that I can
still get the structural form A
squared minus 2A minus 3I out
of this thing by writing it.
Seeing that my first term here
is going to be 2A squared--
so I put a 2 over here--
this gives me my 2A
squared, which I want.
This gives me a minus 4A.
But I want to have
a plus 3A, so I add
on 7A to compensate for that.
This gives me a minus 6I,
which I don't have up here.
So to wipe that
out, I add on a 6I.
In other words, another
way of writing I cubed,
therefore, is this plus this.
And since this is 0, this
says that A cubed is nothing
more than 7A plus 6I.
In fact, in this
particular case,
notice that any power
of A can be reduced
to a linear
combination of A and I,
because as long as I have even
a quadratic power in here,
I can continue my long division.
It's just like
finding a remainder
in ordinary long division.
You keep on going until
the remainder is of a lower
degree than the divisor.
In this particular
case, I've shown you
that A cubed is 7A plus 6I.
And I picked an easy case
just so we could check it.
Notice that we already know
that A squared is 5, 8, 2, 5.
A is 1, 4, 1, 1.
So A cubed is this times this.
Multiplying these
two-by-two's together,
I get this particular matrix.
On the other hand, knowing
that A is 1, 4, 1, 1, 7A
is this matrix, 6I
is this matrix--
and if I now add 7A and 6I--
how do I add?
Component-by-component.
I get 7 plus 6, which is 13, 28
plus 0, which is 28, 7 plus 0,
which is 7, 7 plus
6, which is 13.
In other words, 7A plus 6I is,
indeed, A cubed, as asserted.
And I think you can see now
why I wanted to end here.
From here on in, the course
becomes a very, very technical
subject and one that's
used best in conjunction
with advanced math courses that
are using these techniques.
So we come to the end of part 2.
I want to tell you what
an enjoyable experience
it was teaching you all.
If nothing else, as I
told you after part 1,
I emerge smarter, because it
takes a lot of preparation
to get these boards pre-written.
I couldn't do it alone,
and I would like--
in addition to the camera
people, the floor people,
there are three people who work
very closely with this project
that I would like to single out.
I would like to thank,
especially, John Fitch, who
is the manager of our self-study
project, who also doubles
in as director and producer
of the tape, the film series,
and is also my advisor
for the study guide
and things of the like.
I would like to thank
Charles Patton, who
is the one responsible the
most for the clear pictures
and the excellent photogenic
features that you notice of me,
the sharpness of the camera.
I would also like to thank
Elise Pelletier, who,
in addition to being
a very able secretary,
doubles in in the master control
room as the master everything,
from running the video tape
recorder to making hasty phone
calls and things of this type.
I would also like to thank
two other colleagues, Arthur
[INAUDIBLE] and Paul Brown,
administrative offices
at the center, who have provided
me most excellent working
conditions, and finally,
Harold [INAUDIBLE],, who
was the first
director of the center
and whose idea it was to
produce Calculus Revisited Part
1 and Part 2.
It has been my pleasure.
I hope that our
paths cross again.
But until such a time,
God bless you all.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.